[Music]
hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel today I'm going to show
you all the different ways I know to
start a fire without matches
now some of these methods are more
primitive technologies survivalist style
and others are more MacGyver style but
all of these methods are fun and while I
don't claim to be a master of all these
methods I think you're gonna learn
something new and you're definitely
gonna have a good time okay the first
method I'm gonna show you is my favorite
it is so simple and it's awesome all you
need is a cotton ball a little bit of
leftover soot or ash and send a little
grease and we're gonna make this thing
burn I'm going to unwind the cotton ball
just like that okay I'm taking a little
bit of this ash and I'm gonna sprinkle
it right down in here and roll it like a
burrito as tightly as I can I'm gonna
fold over the edges so it can't come out
the sides I'm going to take about half
the cotton ball maybe three quarters of
the cotton ball and then just tear it
off okay and then I'm going to take this
other piece of 2x4 and we're gonna shape
it just do this three or four times
until it's formed enough that it doesn't
unravel when you roll it the other
direction
now I'm gonna sandwich it between the
two two by fours I'm gonna start rolling
[Music]
you see smoke see ya hold it long boys
like this it encourages the Ember to
grow then there you go how cool is that
so I've been trying this method on and
off for the last six months and doing it
with cotton balls is pretty easy I got
it on like the third try with cotton
balls doing it with paper towels or
toilet paper it's possible I've seen
other people do it but it's much more
difficult whenever you're trying to make
a fire from an ember you need something
that's really highly flammable that you
can put that Ember inside and it'll
burst into flames okay jute works really
well and you can unravel it and make it
into a nest but I'm a dirty cheater and
I like to do it
it is ready to go you put an ember in
that and that'll burst into flames
there you go now I'm gonna show you a
method on how to accidentally start a
fire without matches now you'll notice
behind me I have all of these axes I
like to polish them and preserve them
with linseed oil just this basic boiled
linseed oil that you get at most
hardware stores and if you read the back
of the label carefully it'll tell you to
never leave oil-soaked rags laying about
because they can spontaneously combust
apparently what happens is when you soak
a rag or a paper towel in linseed oil
and expose it to air the chemical
reaction occurs something called it
polymerization or something like that
and it gives off heat and that heat gets
more and more and more until it bursts
into flame and we're gonna see if we can
make that happen without burning our
house down alright got this old kitchen
towel here we're gonna get this thing
smokin polish my spear just put a hole
in the ceiling you know what this
experiment needs more linseed oil now if
you want to see me making all these
Spears and axes definitely check out our
playlist we have forging playlist and
axe restoration playlist alright guys
it's a cold windy day here we're gonna
take all these oily rags
put them in this cardboard box and sit
them on the forge and see what happens
it's been two hours 47 minutes since I
put the rags in this box and it's
starting to smoke actually look at that
the smoke coming out I'm just gonna
leave that here and we'll just see what
happens
well we're just past the three-hour mark
and there's a lot of smoke coming out of
that box so you can smell burning oil so
we'll see we might have flames any
moment now
there we go guys 4 hours 25 minutes this
thing lit up like a candle
starting to melt my GoPro and that is
why you have to be really careful how
you store and dispose of oily rags
there's a lot of fun ways to start fires
with batteries and hopefully I'm about
to show you something you haven't seen
before
alright guys here's a classic steel wall
in a 9-volt battery just put it like
that there you go
if you try doing this with any of the
other standard type batteries they won't
ignite the steel wool unless you take
multiple batteries usually about three
or more put an end end and then they'll
light the steel wall
next we're gonna start a fire by
cracking open one of these lithium
batteries here well there you go you
might end up blind and disfigured but
you can start a fire
with just a battery remember kids don't
try this at home because it explodes and
it catches things on fire next I'm going
to show you the fire piston the fire
piston ignites a fire by super
compressing air when you compress air
suddenly and violently it heats up to
the point where you can ignite a number
you can see here this part slides in
there and it makes a really tight seal
in the tip of the piston is a little bit
of char cloth char cloth is just charred
cloth you take some of this stuff you
burned it up make it into charcoal the
hardest part about the fire piston is
getting the ember from here into your
tinder and getting it into a flame it's
a very very delicate Ember
[Music]
there we go mmm now you can make these
fire Pistons out of wood there's lots of
videos online on how to do that or you
can buy them this one was made by a
company called boost cook I'm not sure
how practical of the tool this is but it
sure is a load of fun let me show you
one of my favorite ways to start a fire
now if you're in the woods in a survival
situation you find this very specific
type of tree look down into the root
system and find where I've stashed a
bottle of potassium manganate and
glycerin and you can use this to start
an amazing fire now potassium manganate
is a very harsh oxidizer you can find in
most hardware stores it's used for water
filtration systems and glycerin is a
common ingredient in homemade soaps and
shampoos and things like that
if you mix the two together you'll get
fired
now if you don't have glycerin
apparently you can use sugar too but the
results are not as good
all right guys classic flint and steel
here another great way to start a fire
with flint and steel there's a couple
things that work really well you got
cotton balls they got steel wool
and see how the three the Juke probably
burns the best now we've got three
different types of flint and steel so
first off this is the blast match you go
and you put the steel on the Ferro rod
like that and works absolutely great and
then you've got the kind with the
magnesium strips here get it up into a
little lie in there there you go
now I've been a lot of you guys are
wondering what happens if you ignite the
entire magnesium bar
one of the more challenging primitive
fire building techniques is the fire
plough method absolutely the bone-dry
Deadwood you can't have any green wood
you can't be wet at all so you can see I
took the pocket knife and Whittle this
down to a bit of an edge there make a
little groove to run the rub the stick
up and down so once you get a good
groove going you need to find a spot to
put your jute
[Music]
over the years I've tried this method a
half-dozen times and I've come close I
can always get smoke for guinea an ember
giving a number that's worth the darn is
hard and it really is an upper-body
workout but all you need is a pocket
knife and the couple pieces of dry wood
to give it a go so definitely give it a
try it's a challenge all right I'm gonna
show you another primitive fire-making
technique the fire saw this is one that
you use with bamboo and I just so
happens and I have a 20 foot long piece
of bamboo from another video I did get a
long piece of bamboo and you want long
so that you can go and put your leg on
there then you take some of your your
tender or jute you slide it under there
you want it to be packed up in there so
that it's touching the top you're gonna
start sawing you just go nice and easy
just cut a groove once you feel like you
got good groove then you start having
pressure
[Applause]
[Music]
four years of making YouTube videos has
not prepared me physically for this but
you can see it it burned the tinder
really well almost made a amber came
darn close to igniting it but my arms
are just toasted oh the Firefly method
in this just ruined me today there's
another technique for the fire so that's
a little bit easier for the back you
take some shorter pieces of bamboo like
this and you get a jacket or something
to act as a pad and you lean against a
board a tree trunk whatever you can then
what you do is you take your tinder you
put it right in there hold it down with
your thumbs and then start working it
oops you see I can chart and do a lot of
songs but I'm not getting a good Ember
okay so this fire starting technique is
kind of cool it was used by ancient
Japanese sword smiths to start their
Forge fires you take a cold piece of
steel or wrought iron and you would beat
it until it turns red hot
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm really getting a workout today it
takes a fair amount of pounding and you
really need a high-quality anvil I do
not have a high quality animal and I
have put this massive dent in my anvil
right there it just is horrible but
there you go that's how you start a fire
but a hammer and a piece of steel
another great method of building fire is
to harness the power of the Sun we've
all used magnifying glasses to burn
leaves and ants and that sort of thing
and if you go online there's tons of
videos about people using ice or bags of
water or even polishing the bottom of
the lumen n'kantu focus the energy of
the Sun and build a fire
unfortunately I picked the absolute
worst time of year to do this part of
the video because it's the dead of
winter and we haven't had a sunny day in
weeks but I'm going to show you one
method that you might not have seen
that's pretty cool you unscrew the
flashlight and pull out the reflector
take a piece of the char cloth wad it up
and you're gonna put it in there then
you're gonna tilt the reflector until
the sun's rays are focused on the char
cloth go get it burning get an ember
going and then you'll dump it in to your
tinder probably the most well-known
method of starting fire without matches
is the spindle inboard method I've got
this little store by spindle and board
kit here just to kind of demonstrate for
you and it's got this bamboo bow here
with the rope wrapped around it and it's
even kind of ball bearings and a little
handle here and you hold this
see this is the trick when you get smoke
coming from your ash pile that's when
you know you've got it there you go
all right we're gonna try to find some
wood and do the spindle method for real
for the spindle you need something long
straight not too many knots it needs to
be bone dry and it needs to be the right
diameter I tend to like to get something
a little bit thicker than I want and
then take my knife and Whittle it down
you're looking for something that's a
softer wood like spruce or pine or even
some of the types of reeds you can use
if you're going to be doing the bow
method you can get away with about five
six inches of spindle you're doing the
hand method you really need 18 to 24
inches of spindle alright I got a little
piece of wood in the drill we're gonna
do a test piece and see if we can get an
ember we can't get a number with the
drill not could get an ember by hand
all right so we made fire with the drill
we know it could be done all right we're
gonna take the thicker pieces and cut
them into boards now only I had an axe
aha
all right there we go there's a board
all right there's a spindle looks good
really straight gonna make another
spindle here a little bit slimmer a
little bit shorter but very straight so
I took a piece of green sapling and
strung some paracord between it for a
bow and I took this little chunk of wood
and burnt a depression into it to make a
handle and we're gonna see if we can't
do the bow and spindle method I've been
at this for three hours I've been
getting tons of smoke I've burned a lot
of holes that's all I got left of my
spindle and my arms are jelly so I think
I'm gonna call it if you want to learn
how to make fire in the woods with just
a pocketknife in your bare hands
learn to do the spindle method without
the boat just using your hand put your
thumbs on the top of the spindle go like
this all the way down putting lots of
downward pressure then reset your hands
and repeat you want a really long smooth
spindle it's got not today they'll to up
your hands if it's not long enough
you'll have to reset too often I spent
two weeks in law school just doing this
over and over again with all sorts of
different types of wood to try to do
this and after two weeks while doing it
in my living room I succeeded and burned
a hole in the carpet my wife never lets
me forget that but what I learned is
that when you have the right type of
wood and the right technique in the
right conditions it happens very fast
you only have to reset about six to 12
times before
you get an ember it happens quickly if
you don't have everything just right you
can do this till the Sun sets and you
will never get it
so it's all about technique and which
materials you use not brute force
there's always something new to learn
and I've just recently discovered a new
method I was done videoing almost done
editing this video and I saw something
online that was really cool there's
something called the Rope liner and it's
an old-timey liner that uses cotton rope
it's basically just a flint and steel
and a rope dispenser and you CH are a
little bit of cotton rope and then flick
some sparks onto it and it creates an
ember on the tip of this rope and you
can store it and use it to light things
and then when you're done you can go and
cap the Rope snuff out the Ember and
store it in your pocket apparently it
was used in like World War one and by
sailors and anyway it was super cool and
maybe I'll go and buy one of these I
just found some on eBay and show them to
you guys in some future videos but just
wanted to throw that out there well I
hope you really enjoyed this video I
sure had a ball making it not all of
these methods are super practical but
they're all a lot of fun so thanks for
watching and don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
Saturday morning if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button so you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]